สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวันนี้
วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้
วันเสาร์ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่
17 เดือนอะไรคะ
ปีค.ศอะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันศุกร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 29
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมิถุนายน
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 11 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมิถุนายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะ
ตอนนี้เวลาเที่ยงคืน
ไหมเที่ยงคืนน่ะ
12 นาทีจริงคือ
เป็นสิ่งที่ผู้หญิงไม่รู้เลยนะว่าเที่ยง
คืนแล้วเขียนยังไงอ่ะ
แล้วก็ 17 นาทีใช่ไหมคะ
ไทยเราเป็น 24 ใช่ไหมคะ 17 เนาะเที่ยงคืน
ก็เป็นเวลากลางคืน
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยชอบกลางคืนใช่ไหม
ใช่ค่ะเขาก็ชอบกลางคืนที่สุดนะนักเรียน
ครูหญิงเนี่ยไม่ชอบกลางคืนนะคะ
อะไร
ก็กลางคืน
ไปเนี่ยมันไม่มีจะมีไฟอ่ะไม่มีมันมืด
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
เวลาที่เราออกไปข้างนอกบ้านน่ะมันก็มืดไง
มันไม่มีดวงอาทิตย์
[เพลง]
ผู้หญิงก็อยากออกไปสิอยู่ในบ้าน
แต่
เวลากลางคืนเนี่ยอยู่ในบ้านก็ได้ถ้าเป็น
เที่ยงคืนเนี่ยโอเคแต่ถ้าเริ่มแบบ
ตี 1 อ่ะตี 1 ก็ยังโอเคนะ
ประมาณตี 2 ไหม
3:00 น
ถ้าเราอยู่ในบ้านเราก็จะอยู่ในห้องนอนใช่
ไหม
แต่ติ๊กต๊อกตี 3 เนี่ยก็เป็นเวลาที่น่า
กลัวนะครูฟ้า
ผู้หญิงกลัวอะไรคะ
อ้าว
ฟ้าไม่กลัวหรอกูหญิงก็กลัว
Teddy  Bear
อะไรจะเป็นแบบนี้ล่ะ
พูดอะไร
นี่ไงตี 2 ตี 3 เนี่ยก็จะมีครูฟ้าเอ้าไม่
ใช่อันนี้อะไรคะ
ผีค่ะครูฝันเนี่ยผีๆอันนี้
มือของผี
ผู้หญิงผีไม่มี
ไม่รู้ผีอาจจะไม่มีแต่ถ้าเป็นเวลาแบบตี 2
ตี 3 เราเนี่ยนอนใช่ไหมนอนอยู่บนเตียง
เนี่ยเราอาจจะไม่เห็นผีแต่เราอาจจะได้ยิน
เสียง
มีอะไรมีคนเดิน
เสียงเดินเป็นยังไงครูฟ้า
ในห้องนอนของเราเนี่ยมีมีหลอดไฟ
ใช่ไหมเราเนี่ยปิดไฟแล้วก็นอนแต่ถ้าตี 2
ตี 3 เนี่ย
หลอดไฟมันอาจจะกระพริบเปิดปิดเปิดปิดเปิด
ปิดเหมือนมีคนเนี่ยจ้างเตียงเรามันอาจจะ
มีสวิตซ์ใช่ไหมมีสวิตซ์แล้วก็กดเปิดปิด
เปิดปิดแต่เราอยู่ในห้องนอนคนเดียวเราไม่
ได้เป็นคนเปิดไฟปิดไฟ
แล้วจะเป็นใครล่ะคะถ้าไม่ใช่ผีหลอกเรา
ครูฟ้าไม่กลัวผีหรอ
อะไรคะ
กลัว
ลุ้นทำไมเนี่ยเออแต่ครูฟ้าเคยบอกว่าอยู่
ออสเตรเลียกลัวน้อยลงใช่ไหม
ใช่มันอเมซิ่งมากนะคะนักเรียนครูฟ้าอยู่
ออสเตรเลียเนี่ย
แต่ครูฟ้าอยู่ประเทศไทยเพราะกลัวมาก
ใช่ถ้าครูฟ้าเนี่ยนอนเนี่ย
เป็นผู้หญิงนะคะผมยาว
เนี่ยถ้าครูฟ้านอนอยู่ในห้องคนเดียวห้อง
นอนตอนกลางคืนแล้วโดนผีหลอกที่ออสเตรเลีย
แล้วกันถ้ามีผีมาหลอกครูฟ้าในห้องนอนครู
ฟ้าจะทำยังไงล่ะ
หลอกเป็นยังไงคะ
นี่ไงผีหลอกเนี่ย
ผี
ผีอาจจะมาเดินต่อไป
หรือว่าผีเนี่ย
ในห้องนอนมีหลอดไฟใช่ไหม
ผีก็อาจจะเปิดปิดเปิดปิดแบบนี้
ปิดแล้วก็เปิดแล้วก็ปิดแล้วก็เปิดแล้วก็
ปิดแล้วก็เปิดแล้วก็ปิดสนุกดีนะแล้วก็
เปิดแล้วก็ปิด
คนเดียวอ่ะไม่มีใครทำอ่ะอยู่ดีๆไฟก็เปิด
ปิดเปิดปิด
มันก็ต้องเป็นผีหลอกไหมล่ะ
แล้วผู้หญิงถามว่าอะไรนะ
แล้วครูฟ้าจะทำยังไง
นักเรียนคะ
ฟ้าเป็นครูพี่กลัว
ผีมากนะคะ
แต่ครูฟ้าก็เป็นคนที่
โกรธ
คือถ้าสมมุติว่า
มีผีมาปิดไฟเปิดไฟปิดไฟเปิดไฟ
ก็จะโกรธนะคะ
แล้วครูฟ้าจะทำยังไงล่ะ
ฟ้าจะพูดอะไรไหม
ว่าจะพูดว่า
ถ้าผีปิดไฟเปิดไฟปิดไฟเปิดไฟนะคะแล้ว
ไฟของครูฟ้ามัน
พัง
ใช้ไม่ได้แล้ว
ครูฟ้าก็จะคิดว่า
กูฟจะ
ไปหาพระ
ต่อยผี
เพราะว่าคนไทยเนี่ยบอกว่า
ครูเราเนี่ยกลัวผีใช่ไหมแต่ผีเนี่ยกลัว
พระ
แต่ถ้าสมมุติ
อะไรนะคะ
เราจะไปหาพระนะคะที่ออสเตรเลียก็มีนะคะ
ออสเตรเลียก็มีวัดไทยใช่ไหมมีวัดไทย
ก็มีพระ
มีพระก็ไปหาพระบอกว่าให้พระเนี่ยมาดีลกับ
ผีซิว่าผีเนี่ยห้ามไปปิดไฟเปิดไฟปิดไฟ
[เพลง]
แล้วมันรู้สึก
[ปรบมือ]
แบบปิดเปิดปิดเปิดปิดเปิดถ้านักเรียนดู
วีดีโอนักเรียนอาจจะแบบผู้หญิงพอได้ไหม
[เพลง]
แต่ถ้าผีเนี่ยไม่ได้มาแค่เปิดไฟปิดไฟ
อี๋มาเป็นตัวผีแบบนี้เลยล่ะ
มาเนี่ยให้ครูฟ้าเห็นว่า
อยู่คนเดียว
แต่มีใครอีกคนนึงกำลังเดินไม่ใช่จะเป็นผี
ใช่มั้ยผี
ผีเนี่ยกำลังเดินๆๆๆๆๆๆๆๆๆๆๆๆๆๆๆ
รอบเตียงที่ครูฟ้าอยู่
อาจจะนอนแล้วก็ห่มผ้าใช่ไหมมีผ้าเนี่ย
แล้วก็คลุม
แล้วก็ได้ยินเสียงเหมือนคนเดินรอบเตียง
คุณฟ้าก็เปิดผ้าออกมาแล้วก็เห็นใครไม่รู้
ไม่ใช่พี่ชายไม่ใช่คนในครอบครัวกูฟ้า
เป็นผีเพราะว่าไม่มีขา
แต่เดินอยู่
เห็นเป็นตัวผีเลย
ครูฟ้าจะทำอะไรไหมจะคุยกับผีไหม
คะนักเรียน
เราต้องช็อคนะคะเวลาเจอผี
ถ้าเราเจอผีหลอกเนี่ย
เราต้องกรี๊ดก็คือ
กรี๊ด
ค่ะ
พี่ชายครูฟ้า
[เพลง]
จะรออยู่ในห้องใช่ไหมไม่วิ่งออกไปข้างนอก
ห้องนอน
นลินคิดนะสมมุติอันนี้คือประตูใช่ไหม
แล้วถ้าผีอยู่ตรงนี้
น้องฟ้าก็ต้องวิ่งมาที่ประตูนะคะ
แต่ครูฟ้ากลัว
ครูฟ้าก็ต้องมาเจอกับผีที่ประตู
แล้วก็เจอแบบใกล้ๆด้วยนะ
ใช่ทำยังไงอ่ะ
ก็เลยใช่ไหมไม่วิ่งออกไปข้างนอกห้อง
แต่ถ้ากูฟ้าคิดว่าครูฟ้านั่ง
อยู่ที่นี่ประมาณ 5 นาทีถึง 10 นาที
คุณฟ้าอาจจะไม่กลัวแล้วเหนื่อย
แล้วแล้วผีก็ยังอยู่แต่ครูฟ้าเนี่ย
กลัวแล้วผีก็ยังแบบอยู่คุณฟ้าจะคุยกับผี
ไหมไม่กลัวแล้วนี่
ก็จะคุยกับฟ้าถามว่า
จะเอาอะไร
อยากได้อะไร
นี่แบบคนไทยเนาะเวลาเราเจอผีเนี่ยเราอาจ
จะคิดว่า
เขาอยากได้อะไรหรือเปล่า
เขาก็เลยมาให้ครูฟ้าเนี่ยเห็นเขาแล้วถ้า
ผีบอกว่า
ผีจะอยากได้อะไรหรอ
นั่นน่ะสิไม่รู้เหอะ
ถ้าครูฟ้าถามผีว่าอยากได้อะไรแล้วเขาบอก
ว่าอยากได้สมมุติอยากได้เอง
คุณฟ้าทำให้ไหม
ถ้าครูฟ้าโอเคครูฟ้าก็ได้โอเคถ้าไม่โอเค
กูฟังก็ไม่ทำ
เหนื่อย
วันนี้ทำงานทำงานทำงานมากๆ
ผีเลิกหลอกได้ไหมอันนี้คือครูฟาร์มไม่ได้
โกรธ
ผีแล้วอ่ะ
ถามอย่างอื่นอีกไหมอ่ะถ้าอยากถามผีและคำ
ถามแรกอยากได้อะไร
มาทำไม
ครูฟ้าคิดว่าผีจะตอบผีเนี่ยจะตอบครูฟ้า
ว่าอะไรถ้าครูฟ้าถามว่ามาทำไม
ก็จะบอกว่า
นี่คือบ้านของผี
อ๋อครูฟ้ามาอยู่ที่บ้านของผีครูฟ้านอนที่
นอนที่เตียงนอนของผีใช่ไหม
อันนี้บ้านของฉันเตียงนอนของฉัน
แต่ฉันจ่ายเงิน
ต้องเอาเงินมา
เพราะว่าบ้านเนี่ยก็ต้องมีแบบค่าไฟใช่ไหม
ค่าไฟค่าน้ำเวลาเราอาบน้ำผีไม่จ่ายนี่ค่า
แอร์ใช่ไหมแอร์หรือว่าฮีตเตอร์ผีไม่จ่าย
ใช่แล้วครูฟ้าใจเงินแพงมาก
เพราะฉะนั้นนี่คือบ้านของครูฟ้าไม่ใช่
บ้านผี
ถ้าผีอยากอยู่กับครูฟ้า
ห้ามพูดว่าบ้านของผีเดี๋ยว
ขอโทษนะคะ
คำถามข้อที่ 1 เนี่ย
คุณก็เริ่มโกรธผีคำถามข้อที่ 2 เนี่ยก็จะ
เป็น
ครูฟ้าอันนี้ครูฟ้าใช่ไหม
VS ผีแล้วนะคะ
ถ้าเป็นผีพูดแบบนี้นี่เป็นผีไม่ดีนะคะตอน
เป็นคนก็ต้องเป็นคนไม่ดีพอตายเป็นผีก็คือ
ไม่ดีด้วย
[เพลง]
ถ้าผีบอกว่านี่บ้านของผีเสร็จแล้วครูฟ้า
มีจะคุยอะไรกับผีอีกไหมหรือทำอะไรผีอีก
ไหมอาจจะไม่คุยก็ได้นะ
พวกเราก็จะบอกเขาว่าถ้าอยากอยู่ที่บ้าน
เอาลอตเตอรี่มา
อ๋อขอลอตเตอรี่ Number
2  3  4  5  6  6 ตัวเลขเนี่ย 6 ตัวอาจ
จะเป็น 2  1  8  7  6  9
ลอตเตอรี่
ให้ลอตเตอรี่ครูฟ้า 6 ตัวแล้วก็ถูกถูกถูก
ถูก
6 ตัวครูฟ้าได้เงินเท่าไหร่นะ 6 ล้านบาท
ไหม
6 ล้านบาท
ไหมคะผีให้ลอตเตอรี่ครูฟ้าถูกเนี่ยว่าบอก
ว่าเดี๋ยวครูฟ้าทำห้องนอน
ตอนนี้ผีด้วยนะคะ
ในห้อง
มีเตียงคู่ฟ้าเตียงผิดเดี๋ยวตอนนี้ครูฟ้า
จะเป็นเพื่อนกับผีแล้วหรอ
โอเคสิเพราะว่าผีช่วยครูฟ้านะคะให้
ลอตเตอรี่ช่วยครูฟ้าจ่ายเงิน
ค่าบ้าน
ก็โอเค
อยู่ได้ก็โอเค
[เพลง]
ต้องให้เยอะๆ
เงินนิดหน่อยก็ไม่ได้ไม่ได้ยังไม่พอ
เงินเยอะๆนะ
ครูฟ้าเจอผีแต่ถ้าเป็นครูหญิงนอนอยู่แล้ว
มีผีมาหลอกในห้องนอนผู้หญิงน่าจะไม่กรี๊ด
เหมือนครูฟ้านะ
ทำไมคะผู้หญิง
กลัวผีรู้ไง
กลัวผีรู้ว่าเราเนี่ยกลัว
เราต้องแบบ
มีเทคนิคให้ผีเนี่ยไป
ยังไงอ่ะผู้หญิง
เราเนี่ยคนไทยใช่ไหมก็ครูฟ้าบอกคนไทยก็มี
วัดใช่ไหมคะ
แล้วก็มีพระ
ห*เนี่ยกลัวพระกลัววัดเวลาที่เรามีผีมา
หลอกในห้องเราเนี่ยเราก็พนมมือนะ
คะ
แล้วก็ให้ผีเนี่ยไปเพราะว่าผีเนี่ยจะกลัว
อะไรที่เกี่ยวกับวัดเกี่ยวกับพระไง
ใช่ค่ะนักเรียนผีกลัวพระนะคะ
แล้วในห้องนอนครูหญิงเนี่ย
เขาเรียกอะไรนะพระที่ห้อยคอภูฟ้า
พระเครื่อง
ในห้องนอนครูหญิงเนี่ยก็จะมีพระแบบนี้
จริงๆเล็กๆนะคะนักเรียนเราก็จะมีอันนี้
เป็นคอใช่ไหมแล้วก็จะมีสร้อย
แล้วก็มีพระห้อยที่คอครูหญิงเนี่ยมีใน
ห้องนอนถ้าผีมาผู้หญิงก็จะเอาพระ
ที่ห้อยคอ
พระที่ห้อยคอเนี่ยแล้วก็
ไป
ไล่ผีไปค่ะ
แต่ไม่กรี๊ด
คิดว่าอย่างแรกเลยถ้าผีหลอกเราในห้อง
เนี่ยเราจะช็อคแบบ
มีผีแล้วเราก็จะคิดทำยังไงแล้วถ้าไม่กลัว
แล้วครูหญิงก็เหมือนครูฟ้าแหละค่ะก็จะถาม
ผีคุยกับผีแล้วค่ะแต่ครูหญิงจะถามด้วยว่า
ตายยังไง
ถามทำไม
อยากรู้
เป็นคนที่ชอบอ่าน
หนังสือ Sherlock  Holmes
ตายยังไงก็เป็นเพื่อนกับผีเหมือนครูฟ้า
นั่นแหละค่ะเนาะแล้วถ้านักเรียนล่ะคะนัก
เรียนเนี่ยไม่ใช่คนไทยอาจจะไม่กลัวผีถ้า
นักเรียนเจอหลอกในห้องนอนจะทำยังไงก็
คอมเมนต์เราได้นะคะแต่ว่าวิดีโอนี้เนี่ย
เดี๋ยวครูฟ้าให้ครูฟ้าเขาไปคุยกับผีก่อน
เป็นผู้หญิงจะไปกินข้าวนะคะเดี๋ยวเรามา
เจอกันใหม่วีดีโอหน้าสวัสดีค่ะ